[Music]
let's say I need to figure out the speed
and feed for a tap I'm about to load
into my machine and I also need to do
the same for an endmill that I'll be
adding to my program the calculator
function on the NGC control makes this
work easy we'll start off with this half
13 tab here we press current commands
and navigate over to the calculator Tab
and then move to the tapping tab my tap
has 13 threads per inch of course or 13
TPI
I enter that here next I enter my
spindle speed for the tapping operation
I'm going to choose 12200 RPM and the
calculator gives me the inch per minute
feed rate of
92377 so now that I've got these two
values I can be assured that the
rotational speed versus the downward
feed rate will be perfectly synchronized
to cut these half 13 threads Just
Right Next let's get the values for this
5/8 carbide endmill
I'll press current commands again to
move back to the tab above and I'll
arrow to the Milling tab I'm just going
to enter the information I'm sure of to
begin with I enter 625 diameter and it's
a four flute endmill so I'll enter that
here that's the basic stuff now I want a
recommendation for surface speed and
Chip load and in order for the control
to give me that I need to tell it what
material I'm using I'll be cutting some
regular mild steel so I arrow down to to
the work material field and select low
carbon steel I also need to make sure my
tool material is correct so I'll change
that to
carbide I'll play it conservative and go
with 500 ft a
minute and that sets my spin RPM to
3056 which I'll probably Round Up to
3100 when I put it in the program next
I'll set my chip load inch per Toth
value on the lower end as well at 4 th
per tooth this gives me a feed rate of
48.890717
correctly also if I want to know the
approximate power required for the cut I
just calculated I just need to go down
here and enter the width and depth of
the cut in these fields here and that
gives me the horsepower
requirement now that I'm confident I
have good starting values for both my
tap and endmill I can get them entered
in my program and be ready to go thanks
for watching